erster tag der haushaltsberatungen hier
und die bundestags vizepräsidentin petra
pau wird jetzt der nächste einzelplan
aufrufen das wird er für familien
senioren frauen und jugend sein ich darf
ihnen sagen im verlauf des tages haben
wir auch noch den einzelplan digitales
und verkehr aber jetzt erstmal erster
redner zum einzelplan familie paul
lehrieder union
2005 familienpolitiker mit leib und
seele und auch zum anderen seit kurzem
auch den haushalt des ministeriums
begleiten diese verantwortung beinhaltet
immer auch einen spagat von inhaltlich
gut und richtig auf der einen seite und
solide finanziert auf der anderen seite
daran müssen sie sich daran muss ich
auch diese haushalt messen lassen wenn
ich mir nun diesen haushalt anziehe dann
kommt es bei beiden herzen zu
rhythmusstörungen soll dass der künftige
weg sein den sie für die familie frauen
senioren und die jugend in unserem lande
gehen wollen wir haben uns als union in
der letzten wahlperiode mit
unterstützung der spd in der ganzen
bandbreite für die menschen dieses
landes eingesetzt von der finanziellen
förderung von familien der unterstützung
bei der besseren vereinbarkeit von
familie und beruf der förderung von
fairen chancen von frauen und männern
dem schutz und der verbesserung von
zukunftschancen von kindern und
jugendlichen über die unterstützung
älterer menschen für ein aktives leben
bis hin zur förderung des
bürgerschaftlichen engagement
das hätte die ampel als blaupause leben
sollen
schaut man sich statt dessen an was
bisher als gesetzentwurf aus dem
ministerium gekommen ist dann stand ist
so als läge das haus noch immer im
dornröschenschlaf der ist der realisten
unter uns würden sagen okay
bisher wenig machen als zu viel falsches
aber wie stärken wir unsere familien was
tun wir um die chancen unserer kinder zu
verbessern wo entlasten wir familien
oder alleinerziehende davon sehe ich im
familien etwa leider viel zu wenig und
das christian wir von der cdu csu völlig
zu recht daher haben wir als unions
fraktion in den haushaltsberatungen
beispielsweise eine deutliche
beschleunigung des kinderbetreuungs
ausbaus gefordert sowie eine aufstockung
des sprach kitas sie alle wissen das
sprache war der schlüssel für die
integration in das gesellschaftliche
leben und der grundstein für den
späteren erfolg in bildung und beruf ist
fehlende sprachliche kompetenzen bei
kindern beeinträchtigen den weiteren
bildungsweg und die integration
erheblichen wir könnten hier so viel
mehr für die ukrainischen kinder tun die
zu uns geflüchtet sind
weiterhin
weiterhin fordern wir dass die
fachkräfte offensive erzieherinnen und
erzieher aufgestockt wird gute
fachkräfte sind der dreh- und angelpunkt
der frühen bildung und integration dass
eine notwendigkeit von der man nicht die
augen verschließen darf
zusätzlich gibt es einen immensen bedarf
derzeit offene stellen zu besetzen
diesen umstand hätten sie
berücksichtigen müssen neben anderen
maßnahmen verliert die union aber auch
gemeinnützige träger in schullandheime
nicht aus dem blick die in der jugend
bildung eine wichtige rolle spielen
durch die bande miesen deren reserven
aufgebraucht sie benötigen daher weitere
unterstützung dafür hat sich die union
in den beratungen ebenfalls eingesetzt
die ampel ignoriert den bedarf
weiterhin haben wir zusätzliche mittel
für die stiftung frühe hilfen gefordert
frühe hilfen stellen niedrigschwellige
und freiwillige angebote für werdende
eltern und familien mit kleinen kindern
bis zum alter von drei jahren in
belastenden lebenslagen darf wir können
hier rechtzeitig etwas für die
schwächsten unserer gesellschaft tun und
helfen gleichzeitig eltern wenn zum
beispiel eine überforderung eingetreten
ist oder sich ankündigt stärkung
ausbaubare kinderbetreuung familien
helfen und alleinerziehende entlasten in
all diesen punkten hätte ich von ihnen
deutlich mehr weit
stattdessen hören und lesen wir alltag
etwas über das demokratie vor dem gesetz
das noch dieses jahr kommen soll malen
sie ernsthaft sie setzen damit die
richtigen schwerpunkte ich appelliere
deshalb besonders an die kolleginnen und
kollegen der fdp es kann nicht aufgabe
des staates sein oder der familie von
der sinn von familienpolitik seien es
flächendeckend und dauerhaft als
gesetzliche leistung zu finanzieren
chance doch bitte noch mal genau hin
in der vorbereitung haben sie vom ersten
zum zweiten regierungsentwurf bereits
die mittel für das programm demokratie
leben kräftig erhöht ungeachtet der
tatsache dass die mittel bisher nur sehr
zögerlich abgerufen worden sind das geld
hätte man anders definitiv sinnvoller
besser investieren können ohne frage
jede form von extremismus auch von links
kommt religiös motiviert ist oder ob von
rechts ist verabscheuungswürdig
da stimmt sie mir sicher zu aber dennoch
muss bei einem entsprechenden programm
auch darauf geachtet werden dass nicht
nur die programmbeschreibung
wohlklingend formuliert ist sondern dass
gegen die feinde unserer demokratie
ausgewogen und stadt wird er einseitig
maßnahmen ergriffen werden
zusammengefasst
sie haben die wichtigsten kannten nicht
genug im blick andere gucken wie zum
beispiel die seniorinnen und senioren
dieses landes die vergessen sie fast
ganz denken sie an die fehlenden 300
oder beim energie entlastungspaket bitte
ihn so gut auch auf die senioren und
auch die haben hilfe verdient
stattdessen stattdessen versuchen sie
anderen bereichen in den bereits jetzt
schon sehr großen block den gesetzlichen
leistungen zu überführen und erhöhen
gleichzeitig noch zusätzlich die
planstellen des ministeriums um sage und
schreibe 90,5 planstellen würden würden
die personalstellen des ministeriums
erhöht daraus viel spaß mit ihren neuen
mitarbeitern das ist weder wurde
familien noch sowie der haushaltspolitik
und wird unsere ansprüchen schlichtweg
nicht gerecht deshalb schauen sie sich
das noch mal an und wie gesagt alles
gute ihnen und den kollegen und kriegen
danke
o'leary da war das der jeden auftrag
gemacht hat zur lesung des einzelplan
familie senioren frauen und jugend er
sitzt im familienausschuss auch im
haushaltsausschuss
der etat ist 12 6 milliarden euro schwer
an ausgaben werden noch einiges zu den
zahlen hören jetzt der nächste redner
bruno hülle für die
grünen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
john lennon sagte einst leben ist das
was passiert während wir andere pläne
schmieden ja wir können die schönsten
pläne für den haushalt machen aber sie
müssen in einem anderen licht betrachtet
werden wenn ein autokratischer herrscher
sein nachbarland überfällt und millionen
menschen zur flucht aus ihrer heimat
singt selbstverständlich muss eine
bundesregierung darauf adäquat reagieren
und zwar auf allen ebenen und in allen
politischen bereichen genau das tut
diese bundesregierung liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen die verantwortung die wir
gemeinsam für die ukraine haben
durchzieht den gesamten bundeshaushalt
bis in den letzten haushaltstitel und
das ist richtig und wichtig so
die
aufgabe des bmf ssj war und ist es nun
denjenigen zur seite zu stehen die alles
verloren haben die ihre schulkameraden
verloren haben ihr kinderzimmer und ja
ein teil ihrer kindheit oder jugend sie
kommen an in einem land dessen sprache
sie nicht sprechen sie haben bomben über
zuhause fallen und menschen sterben
sehen ich möchte hier auch nochmal
ausdrücklich die chance nutzen und allen
bürgerinnen und bürgern in deutschland
für engagement in den letzten monaten
danken danke dass sie ihre türen
geöffnet haben für menschen in der not
danke dass sie gespendet haben geld
kleidung nahrungsmittel ich freue mich
dass ich in einem land lebe dessen
bürger innen so warmherzig so weltoffen
und so hilfsbereit sind
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen es ist
jetzt unsere pflicht als bundesregierung
in zusammenarbeit mit den ländern dafür
zu sorgen dass den menschen die bei uns
unterkommen eine echte chance auf einen
neustart geboten wird und da sind eben
auch die länder in der pflicht mehr zu
tun als bisher wir haben als
parlamentarische als als grüne die als
das bfj in diesen zeiten mit den
notwendigen finanziellen mitteln
ausgestattet wir wissen wir können nicht
gegen die krise ansparen wir brauchen
eine aktive haushaltspolitik und das
eben auch in den ländern jetzt wir haben
den kinder- und jugendplan im vergleich
zu 2021 um rund 66 millionen euro
aufgestockt auf 300 millionen euro dabei
haben wir ein besonderes augenmerk auf
kinder und frauen gelegt es gibt
zusätzliche mittel für schwangere frauen
in not und es wird eine
koordinierungsstelle für waisenkinder
geben denn es gehört eben auch zu den
schrecken des krieges dass gerade die
schutzbedürftigsten am frühesten und am
stärksten leiden und daher ist diese
koordinierungsstelle so wichtig gerade
um schnellstmöglich dafür zu sorgen dass
den kindern das ankommen und weiterleben
hier bei uns überhaupt ermöglicht werden
kann genau das stellen wir über diesen
einzelplan 17 sicher und das sollte
nicht untergehen
wir haben
wir haben einiges erreicht auch noch mal
im parlamentarischen verfahren 8
millionen euro mehr für die jugend
migrationsdienst drei millionen euro
mehr für die jugendverbandsarbeit und
damit für gerechte teilhabe jugendlicher
an der gesellschaft die us back coaches
die an schulen zu den themen demokratie
verständnis toleranz oder extremismus
prävention arbeiten fördern wir mit 15
millionen euro zusätzlich und auch bei
der psychosozialen beratung bei den
psychosozialen zentren eine aufgabe die
in den letzten jahren massiv
vernachlässigt wurde stellen wir jetzt
die notwendigen haushaltsmittel bereit
das sind alles noch mal wichtige
haushaltsposten die langfristig wirken
und so manche altlast beseitigen
und natürlich
natürlich liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ist es auch ist auch eine andere krise
in unserem bewusstsein die über diesen
einzelplan adressiert werden muss die
folgen der korona pandemie sind eben
noch längst nicht überstanden kinder und
jugendliche mussten die letzten zwei
jahre besonders unter den
einschränkungen leiden das bmf sj stellt
daher 272 millionen euro zur bewältigung
der korona folgen im familiären bereich
zur verfügung das sind im wahrsten sinne
des wortes investitionen in unsere
zukunft und natürlich werden bei
haushaltsverhandlungen auch die
verschiedenen prioritäten der einzelnen
koalitionspartner innen deutlich dass es
selbstverständlich ich möchte ja nicht
verhehlen dass wir uns als grüne mehr
unterstützung auch aus dem
finanzministerium gewünscht hätten vor
allem mit blick auf die finanzplanung
der gesellschaftliche zusammenhalt ist
eines der wichtigsten ziele unserer
politik und das fundament dafür das
liegt eben im familienministerium unsere
demokratie das friedliche zusammenleben
aller hier lebenden menschen muss
unbedingt geschützt und ja auch
gefördert werden das klappt aber eben
nicht mit lippenbekenntnissen dafür
müssen förderprogramme finanziell auch
langfristig gut ausgestattet seien
kinder jugend familie
und gesundes altern das ist nicht
nachrangig das ist der kitt der
gesellschaft zusammenhält und deswegen
müssen wir alle die familienpolitik zu
unserer gemeinsam haushaltspolitischen
priorität machen das geht vor allem auch
an den finanzminister und zum abschluss
zum abschluss möchte ich noch einmal
darauf hinweisen was es haushälterisch
dann eben doch für den unterschied macht
zwischen der vorgängerregierung mit der
union und der jetzigen regierung ohne
die union seit jahren sind demokratie
förderprogramme unterfinanziert das
wissen sie aber dass sie eben gerade
jetzt im parlamentarischen verfahren bei
programm kürzen wollen wie menschen
stärken menschen oder demokratie leben
das ist nicht zu verstehen und das macht
deutlich
dass sie nicht verstanden haben welche
bedeutung maßnahmen der extremismus
prävention und der demokratie förderung
für unseren zusammenhalt in der
gesellschaft haben nein liebe union wir
nehmen die förderung einer lebenswerten
gesellschaft der vielen sehr sehr ernst
und die menschen in deutschland können
sich darauf verlassen dass wir als
ampelkoalition dass wir als grüne
konsequent dafür arbeiten und dafür
kämpfen dass kinder gerechte chancen
haben dass sie keine armut leben müssen
und dass sie diskriminierungsfrei
aufwachsen können herzlichen dank
bruno höhne war das für die fraktion
bündnis 90/die grünen und er hat noch
mal einige punkte genannt die aus seiner
sicht noch mal verbesserung gebracht
haben für diesen einzelplan für
verschiedene programme in der
bereinigungssitzung die
bereinigungssitzung um das noch mal zu
sagen das ist ja jene sitzung des
haushaltsausschusses wo die alle posten
noch mal angeschaut werden 15 stunden
hat die gedauert vor zwei wochen und
dann stand der haushalt
wir sind uns alle hier
fraktionsübergreifend einig dass die
familie das a und o unserer gesellschaft
ist und obwohl es diese einschätzung ein
zeigt ihre konkrete politik etwa wenn es
um das finanzielle geht sehr schnell
dass es fundamentale unterschiede gibt
zwischen dem gesagten und dem konkreten
ich habe bereits das bei der ersten
lesung gesagt und ich sage es noch
einmal 600 millionen euro weniger für
den familien etat ist angesichts der
lage in der wir uns derzeit befinden ein
fatales signal
gerade jetzt inmitten der größten
inflation seit jahrzehnten und nach zwei
jahren pandemie mir scheint es als ob
bei der rot grünen ampel die verbindung
zur realität vollkommen abhanden
gekommen ist anders kann ich mir diesen
haushalt nicht erklären meine fraktion
und ich können uns und können uns auch
nicht erklären wieso sie gleichzeitig
ausgaben für völlig ideologische
projekte erhöhen aber über wichtigen
ausgaben plötzlich sparsam unterwegs
sind es sollte gerade anders herum
laufen wir sind in einer krise es ist
derzeit die prioritäten anders zu setzen
lassen sie es mich einmal mit konkreten
beispielen anschaulich machen unter dem
berühmten titel maßnahmen zur stärkung
von vielfalt toleranz und demokratie
findet man projekte wie mehr chancen
patenschaften impuls patenschaften
witamin p chancen patenschaften im
übergang zwischen schule und beruf sie
selbst neue strategische kommunikation
zur neubesetzung des islam narratives in
deutschland und so weiter insgesamt sind
es mehrere hundert projekte dotiert mit
mehreren hundert millionen euro fast
alle dieser projekte haben eine nahezu
identische beschreibung das heißt hat
man einige lesen hat man fast alle
gesehen das prinzip läuft ganz einfach
eine schöne bunte internetseite mit
vielen stock fotos erstellen eine
broschüre mit vielen passwörtern wie
netzwerk koordinierung engagement und
brücken bauen schreiben dabei ganz ganz
viel ändern und voila sie haben sich für
die förderung qualifiziert ob es ein
mehrwert gibt egal dazwischen finden
sich dann auf dubiose stiftungen wie die
antonio amodeo stiftung mit mittlerweile
einem jahresbudget von fünf millionen
euro die sich offensichtlich im
selbstbedienungsladen des
familienministeriums sehr gut auskennen
und diese strukturen werden jahr für
jahr mit immer mehr geld freudig
finanziert ähnlich wird es auch unter
anderen titeln wie etwa bei der
qualifizierungsoffensive da heißen
karten schaffte neben respekt coaches 23
millionen werden dafür fachkräfte der
jugendmigrationsdienst
ausgegeben die das machen was die
eigentliche aufgabe von lehrern und
eltern ist respekt und toleranz ist
nicht etwas wofür noch zusätzliche und
neue staatliche strukturen brauchen
zumal darunter ganz viel indoktrinierung
über gander weiße privilegien oder
ähnliches getätigt wird nebenbei bemerkt
weil das soll dann an kaputt gesparten
schulen stattfinden finde den fehler
verstehen sie mich nicht falsch eine
lebhafte zivilgesellschaft ist durchaus
erstrebenswert nur das ausmaß dass diese
so genannten angeles mittlerweile ein
die einseitigkeit dieser projekte und
die vollkommene konturlosigkeit strengen
jeglichen rahmen da wäre ein erhebliches
einsparpotenzial vorhanden das haben wir
als ard gefordert leider vergebens was
machen sie sie geben dort noch mehr geld
aus das ist klientelpolitik und nicht
politik die für die familien in unserem
land auch bei der förderung der achtung
nicht parteipolitischen aufgaben der
jugendorganisation politischer parteien
legen sie nach das heißt linksjugend
grüne jugend jusos und co bekommen
steuergeld für ihre nicht
parteipolitische arbeit ein unwort in
sich anstatt das geld zu streichen wir
vorgeschlagen haben haben sie die gelder
dazu sogar verdoppelt zack 4 millionen
wecken sie geben ihren eigenen
jugendorganisationen steuergeld und die
familien sollen in die röhre gucken und
fassbar wo wir als fdp das geld besser
angelegt sehen ist etwa bei den
zuschüssen für die instandhaltung von
familienferienstätten beim deutschen
müttergenesungswerk bei den
unterstützungsleistungen bei ungewollter
kinderlosigkeit oder für den ausbau der
hilfen für schwangere und zur regelung
der vertraulichen geburt insgesamt 50
millionen mehr das sind buchstäblich
greifbare maßnahmen und nicht
irgendwelche ideologischen papier
projekte das würde beim bürger
tatsächlich ankommen
meine damen und herren ich komme zum
schluss wir haben ihnen als opposition
aufgezeigt sowie geld sparen können und
wo wir es dagegen viel besser investiert
sehen den von ihnen vorgeschlagenen
haushalt für das familienministerium
können wir in der form nicht mittragen
und werden ihn ablehnen und einen satz
muss ich zum schluss noch zu dem umgang
mit den suchenden mit dem sogenannten
ergänzungs haushalt verlieren obwohl
vielfach versprochen auch von ihnen
persönlich frau ministerin über die
genaue ausgestaltung der zusätzlichen
mittel stochern wir immer noch im nebel
diese pauschal buchung im einzelplan 60
ist alles andere als transparent so geht
man mit dem haushaltsgesetzgeber nicht
um ich bedanke mich für die
aufmerksamkeit
ulrike ziesing war das für die afd sie
ist berichterstatterin für diesen
einzelplan im haushaltsausschuss gibt es
hier jeweils bei den fraktionen noch mal
abgeordnete die ganz speziell eben auf
die verschiedenen einzelpläne gucken da
sind dann die berichterstatterin und
berichterstatter für den einzelplan die
auch meistens in der dritten lesung am
anfang der debatte noch mal sprechen
jetzt elisabeth kaiser die
berichterstatterin für die spd fraktion
es ist ein jahr das geprägt ist von der
korona pandemie immer noch und ihren
folgen für unsere gesellschaft ein jahr
in dem seit februar seit über drei
monaten krieg in europa herrscht und die
inflation die sorgenfalten in den
gesichtern der mitbürgerinnen mitbürgern
größer werden lässt der angriff der
russischen regierung auf die ukraine hat
die welt hat uns alle fassungslos
gemacht viele ukraine ukraine von ganz
klein bis ins hohe alter
sie sind gezwungen waren gezwungen ihr
land hals über kopf zu verlassen und in
anderen ländern schutz und sicherheit zu
suchen es kommt nun darauf an dass wir
hier im parlament die entscheidungen
treffen um für diese für diese aktuellen
und künftigen herausforderungen gut
aufgestellt zu sein als koalition setzen
wir schwerpunkte für eine starke politik
für familien kinder jugendliche und
ältere menschen wir investieren in den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt in dem
wir engagierte und vielfältige
zivilgesellschaft fördern und wir
kümmern uns um menschen die vor dem
krieg zu uns geflüchtet sind hier schutz
und perspektive suchen
ich möchte
müsste im folgenden erläutern wo sich
diese schwerpunkte im haushalt konkret
wiederfinden und was du im
parlamentarischen verfahren noch ein
verbesserungen bei führen konnten mit
blick auf die korona pandemie es
festzustellen dass allein 272 millionen
euro in diesem jahr zur verfügung stehen
um ihre folgen für kinder und
jugendliche abzufedern der kinder- und
jugendplan dem zentralen
förderinstrument des bundes in der
kinder und jugendhilfe haben wir durch
die parlamentarischen beratungen
insgesamt um 28,1 millionen euro
gegenüber dem regierungsentwurf erhöhen
können und damit damit stärken wir
damit stärken wir zum beispiel
jugendverbandsarbeit denn sie trägt dazu
bei dass junge menschen unabhängig von
ihrer sozialen herkunft die möglichkeit
erhalten selbst wirksam zu sein und
eigentlich zu eigenverantwortlichen
persönlichkeiten zu entwickeln und
persönlich freue ich mich sehr über den
verhandlungserfolg im bereich der
kulturellen jugendbildung die
musikakademie rheinsberg ist seit 2001
die erste und einzige bundesakademie für
junges musiktheater mit sitz in
ostdeutschland und sie erhält nun auch
mehr mittel mit zusätzlichen 35
millionen euro aus dem ergänzungs
haushalts verstärken er bezieht auch
maßnahmen mit dem wir vor allem den
frauen und kindern sowie traumatisierten
menschen helfen die vor dem krieg in der
ukraine hierher fliegen mussten wichtig
ist aber nun dass die hilfen schnell und
zielgerichtet dort ankommen wo sie
gebraucht werden die stiftung mutter und
kind beispielsweise bietet wertvolle und
unbürokratische hilfen für schwangere in
schwierigen persönlichen situation und
notlagen sie stärken wir mit
zusätzlichen mitteln und insgesamt 5,5
millionen euro und wie bei harry reid
auch die stiftung frühe hilfen alt
ebenfalls zusätzliche mittel und darüber
können familien und säuglinge und
kleinkinder zwischen sozialer
unterstützung erhalten
wichtig war uns auch im
parlamentarischen verfahren eben gerade
die jugend migrationsdienst besser
auszustatten
diese rund 490 dienste unterstützen
bereits bundesweit junge menschen mit
flucht erfahrung in ihrer
persönlichkeitsentwicklung durch
beratung und enge begleitung zu allen
fragen rund um ihre integration
wir wollen damit zu mehr
chancengerechtigkeit für diese kinder
und jugendlichen beitragen
im engen zusammenhang dazu stehen auch
die respekt coaches die coaches sind
pädagogische fachkräfte die schülerinnen
und schülern dabei helfen den wert einer
vielfältigen gesellschaft zu erfahren zu
unterstützen jungen menschen dabei den
eigenen blickwinkel zu erweitern und
wollten damit auch den entstehen von
vorurteilen vor und leider waren die
dafür vorgesehenen mittel noch nicht im
regierungsentwurf abgebildet aber es ist
gesund diese wichtige arbeit abzusichern
und planungssicherheit zu geben und an
dieser stelle liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen möchte ich auch noch mal die
bedeutung von demokratie forderung
deutlich hervor ich glaube das ist auch
nach dieser letzten rede manchmal sehr
notwendig um die akteure der
zivilgesellschaft
und ihrem wichtigen und oft nicht
ungefährlichen engagement für eine
lebendige und wehrhafte demokratie zu
unterstützen ist es wichtig und richtig
dass diese koalition hier einen
schwerpunkt setzt das zeigt sich unter
anderem auch bei den gestiegenen mitteln
für das bundesprogramm demokratie leben
um somit aktiv oder warum aber effektiv
zu gestalten ist es nicht nur wichtig
sich finnlands sehr gut abzusichern
sondern auch darauf zu achten welche
ideologien und entwicklungen unsere
freiheitliche und vielfältige demokratie
gefährden rassismus gehört dazu die
bekämpfung von rassismus ist eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche aufgabe
eine besondere rolle kommt dabei dem
2017 gegründeten deutschen zentrum für
integration migrationsforschung dem ds
hin zu den nationalen diskriminierung
und rassismus monitor nadia genannt
untersucht dass die zum ursachen ausmaß
und folgen von rassismus in deutschland
ziel ist es entwicklungen und trends in
bezug auf rassismus zu erfassen und
daraus wiederum impulse für demokratie
forderungen und andere mögliche
handlungsfelder zu geben und ich bin
sehr froh dass wir die wichtige
forschungsarbeit mit zusätzlichen 4,8
millionen absichern konnten
demokratie
lebt aber natürlich auch zum
bürgerschaftlichen engagement deshalb
ist es gut dass wir als koalition die
freiwilligendienste in den kommenden
jahren bedarfsgerecht weiter fördern
wollen und die mittel für das
partnerschaftsprogramm menschen stärken
menschen erhöhen all diese maßnahmen
sind so wichtig für ein gutes
miteinander und stärken den zusammenhalt
in unserer gesellschaft und lassen sie
mich abschließend noch ein liegt im
blick auf einen bereich der
seniorenpolitik lenken mit zusätzlichen
mitteln zu sichern wir das modellprojekt
zukunftswerkstatt kommunen attraktiv im
wannsee ab und hier geht es darum
regionen abseits der großstädte mittels
demokratie demografie strategien für
ältere menschen attraktiv zu halten und
ihre teilhabe weiter zu fördern und ich
muss sagen dass abgeordnete aus
thüringen weiß ich wie wichtig diese
projekte sind die liebe kollegen bewegen
ich denke dass wir den regierungsentwurf
an der einen oder anderen stelle noch
verbessern konnten ich möchte mich an
dieser stelle auch sehr herzlich bei
meinen mit berichterstatterin und mit
der berichterstatter aber auch bei dem
ministerium für die gute zusammenarbeit
bedanken wichtig finde ich jetzt vor
allen dingen dass die nun gesetzten
schwerpunkte in den kommenden jahren
fortgesetzt werden und wir gleichzeitig
wichtige maßnahmen aus dem
koalitionsvertrag angehen können
stichwort eine kinder grundsicherung um
das qualitätssicherungs gesetz da ist
jeder euro sehr gut angelegt vielen dank
elisabeth kaiser für die spd-fraktion
mit berichterstatterin und gstadt dann
habt ihr gedankt also jenen abgeordneten
aus dem haushaltsausschuss die auf
diesen einzelplan schauen auch gesine
lötzsch ist berichterstatterin für
diesen einzelplan für die linke
unter dem furchtbaren krieg russlands
gegen die ukraine leiden vor allem
kinder frauen und alte menschen sie
leiden in der ukraine aber auch in
vielen anderen armen ländern der welt
und sogar in unserem reichen land und
darum ist unsere klare forderung dieser
krieg muss sofort beendet werden als
ersten schritt brauchen wir einen
sofortigen waffenstillstand und dafür
muss sich die bundesregierung einsetzen
in den medien wird jeden tag hartnäckig
nachgefragt wann die bundesregierung
denn endlich noch mehr waffen in das
kriegsgebiet liefern werde ich sage
ihnen aber viel zu selten höre ich die
frage wann die bundesregierung dann
endlich wirksam gegen abend und hunger
etwas tut ich sage ihm dazu tut die
bundesregierung viel zu wenig und das
muss sich ändern
jedes fünfte kind in deutschland gilt
als auch nichts gefährdet und das ist
beschämend die galoppierende inflation
betrifft alleinerziehende und paare mit
kindern die nur ein geringes oder
mittleres einkommen haben besonders hart
das gewerkschaftsnahe institut für
makroökonomie und konjunkturforschung
hat nachgewiesen die bundesregierung
entlastet alleinerziehende nur
unzureichend und er den ersten vier
monaten dieses jahres haben die
preissteigerung schon mehr als die
hälfte der versprochenen entlastungen
verschlungen und allein leben damit
niedriger rente sind auf jeden fall im
minus die menschen müssen jetzt und
sofort und konkret entlastet werden kann
und traub aus wenn ich dem handelsblatt
entnehmen dass sie erst im jahr 20 25
also am ende der regulären
regierungszeit eine kindergrundsicherung
vorlegen wollen ein gesetz dazu dann
sage ich ihnen das ist deutlich zu spät
warum gerade ist die wahren kann diese
regierung in ein paar wochen ein
sondervermögen bundeswehr von 100
milliarden euro aus dem boden stampfen
aber schafft es nicht innerhalb eines
jahres eine kindergrundsicherung zu
verabschieden das ist doch ein
widerspruch das nehmen wir nicht hin
meine damen und herren
diese kindergrundsicherung muss aber
dafür sorgen dass arme kinder wirklich
auch eine verbesserung erleben und die
bisherigen modelle haben das leider noch
nicht drin meine damen und herren bis
zur einführung der kindergrundsicherung
wollen sie von der regierung die kinder
mit almosen abspeisen
dabei hat die diakonie schon berechnet
dass kinder in der grundsicherung
durch 78 euro zu wenig erhalten das was
sie ihm jetzt geben wollen ist viel zu
wenig und das ist ein wirkliches anders
meine damen und herren
der kinder in armut aufwachsen lässt
stiehlt diesen kinder nicht nur kindheit
jugend und zukunft sondern schadet der
gesamten gesellschaft das durch nicht
zulassen vielen dank
gesine lötzsch war dass die auch
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
der linksfraktion ist
und ihr folgt jetzt wenn ich mit
gezielter bin ich richtig mitgezählt hat
viele letzte aus der berichterstatterin
riege claudia raffelhüschen für die fdp
in dieser woche gehen die beratungen für
den haushalt
2022 zu ende für uns waren das sehr
aufregende und fordernde wochen an
dieser stelle daher meinen herzlichen
dank an meine kollegen kollegin
insbesondere mein ampel kollegen
danke für die effiziente und völlig
geräuschlose zusammenarbeit es hat
wirklich prima geklappt ich freue mich
dass wir als ampel auch in der letzten
haushalts runde der bereinigung nochmal
für verschiedene gruppen in der
bevölkerung nachbessern konnten für
senioren für jugendliche für frauen und
kinder die frauen um kinder die aus der
ukraine zu uns geflohen sind
unterstützen wir in besonderer weise
fast 2,5 millionen euro fließen im
finanzielle hilfen speziell für
schwangere frauen aus der ukraine und
noch einmal 1,6 millionen euro gibt es
für die integrationskurs begleitende
kinder beaufsichtigung denn nur so
ermöglichen wir den müttern ihren
kindern ein gutes und schnelles ankommt
in unserer gesellschaft
sehr zuversichtlich stimmt mich die
tatsache dass wir mit ministerin pausen
eine finanzexperten an der hausspitze
haben die weiß wie man mit steuergeldern
umzugehen hat denn eines auch klar die
nächsten haushalte werden sich einfacher
für uns der fast permanente krisen modus
in dem wir uns als gesellschaft leider
seit über zwei jahren befinden darf für
uns haushälter nicht den blick auf die
aufgaben verstellen die ganz
grundsätzlich und jenseits des krieges
und pandemien vor uns liegen und das
insbesondere vor dem hintergrund dass
wir gleichzeitig ab 2023 die
schuldenbremse wieder einhalten wollen
denn wir haben als koalition in diesem
einzelplan noch einige sehr ehrgeizige
projekte vor uns ich nenne hier nun mal
exemplarisch die kindergrundsicherung
und die fortsetzung des gute kita
gesetzes wenn der bund sich bei diesen
großen und wichtigen projekten
substanziell engagieren soll müssen wir
allerdings auch so ehrlich sein zu
priorisieren auch wenn es manchmal weh
tut meine persönliche priorität im
einzel platz 17 liegt bei den kindern
sie sind unsere zukunft sie haben in
zwei jahren von allen gruppen am meisten
verkraften und entbehren müssen und sie
haben in deutschland verglichen mit
anderen worten zum beispiel den senioren
leider traditionell keine besonders
starke lobby wir als haushälter und
haushälterinnen des einzel platz 17
können durchaus dazu beitragen dass
kinder ihr nicht hinten runterfallen die
272 millionen euro zusätzliche mittel im
chor ohne aufruf programm wann ein sehr
guter anfang noch besser war es dass wir
als ampel mit unseren änderungen einen
noch stärkeren fokus auf kinder und
mütter gelegt haben die hilfen
insbesondere für die ukraine habe ich
schon genannt in dieselbe kategorie
gehören für mich die zusätzlichen mittel
in der schwangerschaftskonfliktberatung
denn hilfe für mütter und ihre kinder
ist leider manchmal schon dringend nötig
bevor diese kinder überhaupt geboren
werden können und ich freue mich sehr
dass wir die frauen in dieser
existenziellen ausnahmesituation auch
weiterhin nicht alleine lassen
genauso wichtig wie die überzeugung mit
den geldern in unserem etat absolut
sinnvolle projekte zu unterstützen ist
mir aber auch die maxime ausgaben so
weit irgend möglich gegenzufinanzieren
und immer wieder kritisch zu
hinterfragen ob einmal eingestellte
budgets wirklich effizient genutzt
werden und natürlich ob sie weiterhin
benötigt werden auch in diesem punkt bin
ich sehr froh in meinen ampel kollegen
zwei gleichgesinnte getroffen zu haben
komplett unverständlich ist mir dagegen
das verhalten der opposition
insbesondere der grünen über
siebeneinhalb milliarden euro
zusätzliche wünsche und das netto da
hätte ich mir schon ein kleines bisschen
mehr seriosität erhofft oppositionsrolle
hin oder her natürlich können wir im
einzelplan 17 eine menge geld für kinder
und familien verteilen das ganze ist
aber ziemlich kurz gedacht man könnte
auch sagen verlogen wenn wir den
zukünftigen generationen
wenn wir den zukünftigen generationen
gleichzeitig mit neuen wohltaten
ungeheure neue schulden hinterlassen nur
wenn wir beides zusammenbringen wird ein
schuh draus kluge und nachhaltige
ausgaben wo sie nötig sind und gut
begründete einsparungen dort wo sie
möglich sind anders lässt sich die
generationengerechtigkeit nicht erfüllen
von der ja immer wieder gerne und viel
gesprochen wird die aber auch finanziell
solide unterfüttert sein muss wenn wir
sie denn ernst nehmen mein ziel als
liberale und insbesondere als mutter ist
und bleibt es jedenfalls die
schuldenbremse ab 2023 wieder
einzuhalten nach diesem
haushaltsverhandlungen kann ich sagen
dass ich damit offensichtlich in der
richtigen fraktion angesiedelt bin und
freue mich darauf mich weiterhin mit
meinen kollegen für solide
staatsfinanzen
und eine lebenswerte zukunft unserer
kinder einzusetzen gehen ja der während
der bundestag hier mitten in den
haushaltsberatungen steckt mitten im
etat familie senioren frauen und jugend
haben wir natürlich auch ein auge und
das schon mal als vorankündigung das was
in brüssel passiert da haben sich ja die
staats und regierungschefs getroffen und
es gibt einen kompromiss zu einem
ölembargo gegen russland vielleicht ein
eher ein öl-embargo leid wir erwarten
die abschlusspressekonferenz einmal von
bundeskanzler olaf scholz der ebenfalls
noch in brüssel ist aber auch von
eu-ratspräsident carl michele und
eu-kommissionspräsident in von der leyen
werden an den bundestag kurz verlassen
sie können übrigens im bundestag weiter
auf unserer seite verfolgen
phoenix.de im stream und wer mir dann
nach brüssel gehen wie gesagt bundestag
können sie weiter für freunde bleiben
aber er ist natürlich solange noch hier
in der debatte spricht sylvia breher für
die union
dafür sozusagen mangelnde unterstützung
vorwerfen aber wie gesagt das nehmen wir
zur kenntnis in der sache selber sind
wir uns glaube ich eigentlich dass
insbesondere der bereich der
kinderbetreuung eine der zentralen
aufgaben dieser zeit sind also weitere
betreuungsplätze und mehr personal und
sie stellen jetzt den ländern sie haben
es mehrfach angesprochen pauschal unter
anderem eine milliarde zur verfügung
durch den erhöhten anteil an der
umsatzsteuer um die kosten mit den
geflüchteten im bereich gesundheit und
pflege kinderbetreuung und büsche und
beschulung
auszugleichen wir haben sie ermutigt
hier zweckgebunden vorzugehen die mittel
einzusetzen für ein investitionsprogramm
kinderbetreuung denn das letzte das
fünfte investitionsprogramm kita der
letzten bundesregierung läuft jetzt aus
und es gibt hier keine
anschlussfinanzierung ihr votum leider
ablehnung wir haben sie ermutigt dass
auch von ihnen als erfolgreich
beschriebene fachkräfte offensive das
programm was im sommer endet für die
erzieherinnen der zia fortzusetzen der
mangel an fachkräften ist riesig aber
auch hier ihre empfehlung ablehnung wir
haben sie ermutigt die mittel für die
sprach- kitas auszuweiten denn sprache
ist der schlüssel zur welt und das war
im übrigen liebe kollegen von der fdp
auch eine zentrale forderung ihrer
fraktion noch zum haushalt 21 aber da
waren sie in der opposition jetzt in der
regierung ablehnung wir haben sie
ermutigt die so wichtigen ölhäfen
auszubauen den belasteten familien
gerade am start zur seite zu stehen sie
zu unterstützen
ihr vorwurf in anderen haushaltsjahren
aus der opposition heraus einfach weiter
so jetzt muss ich leider sagen das gilt
für sie ein aufwuchs ihr votum ablehnung
einfach weiter so das gilt im übrigen
auch für die freiwilligendienste im
haushalt 21 hat die parlamentarische
staatssekretärin lediglich es noch
gesagt wir brauchen ein ausbau der
freiwilligendienste damit alle
interessierten jugendlichen zum zuge
kommen jetzt leider keine verstetigung
ausschließlich und eine forderung und
ich denke dass ein club liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von den grünen
aber auch von der fdp die verstetigung
der mittel für das gute kita gesetzt
denn diese mittel laufen ende dieses
jahres aus und die länder brauchen hier
die bundespolitische unterstützung der
ausblick allerdings ist und bleibt
düster in den eckwerten
0,0 euro einfach nichts für die
kommenden jahre das wird eine
kernaufgabe seien für die kommenden
haushalte schon ab september in den
nächsten beratungen und wir werden sie
da auch an ihren eigenen forderungen
messen
und abschließend aus aktuellem anlass
uns geht davon aus dass die frau
ministerin dort darauf eingehen wird
weil es einfach so ein brennendes thema
ist das bka hat gestern die aktuellen
zahlen zum kindesmissbrauch zur
sexuellen gewalt an kindern
veröffentlicht und diese zahlen sind
nicht nur erschreckend ich habe dafür
einfach gar keine worte
17.700 vier kinder sind im vergangenen
jahr opfer von sexuellem missbrauch
geworden besitz herstellung verbreitung
kinderpornografischen materials haben
sich innerhalb eines jahres mehr als
verdoppelt
frau ministerin paus sie sind gemeinsam
mit dem bundesinnenministerium die
schutz anwältin für die kinder nehmen
sie diese aufgabe bitte ernst
datenschutz darf nicht länger
täterschutz sein zeigen sie dass dieses
thema priorität in dieser
bundesregierung hat lassen sie vor allem
die kinder nicht im stich und in diesem
thema haben sie uns an ihrer seite das
kann ich ihnen zu sagen vielen dank
sagte silvia breher für die
unionsfraktion die sprecherin für
familie senioren frauen und jugend und
schaut schon mal in richtung
regierungsbank denn hier die ministerin
leser porträtiert als nächste sprechen
seit 27 april ist sie ja hier an der
spitze dieses hauses
das familienministerium
werte kolleginnen und kollegen
zu hören dass seit 96 tagen wird nun
russlands präsident putin krieg gegen
die ukraine mehr als 6,5 millionen
menschen sind geflohen mehr als 750.000
davon nach deutschland
der krieg und die sanktionen gegen den
russischen des boten sie haben
inzwischen spürbare auswirkungen auch
bei uns
steigende energiekosten
lebensmittelpreise sie belasten unsere
wirtschaft lasten auf unsere
gesellschaft und auch bewohner hat bei
uns allen seine spuren hinterlassen
umso wichtiger ist es dass wir den
sozialen zusammenhalt und die soziale
gerechtigkeit miteinander
genau darauf kommt es an meine damen und
herren
denn wem ist bereits vor kohler
wirtschaftlich nicht gut ging der muss
jetzt erst recht jeden cent umdrehen bei
dem cad der euro jeden tag
in meinem haus stehen in diesem jahr
rund 12,6 milliarden euro zur verfügung
und ich danke ganz herzlich allen
haushälterin und haushältern liebe
kolleginnen kollegen dafür
und dann ihn investiert mein haus
erstens in die zukunft von familien
deshalb bekommen alle kinder die in
familien mit wenig oder kein reinkommen
groß werden den sofort zuschlag von 20
euro im monat zusätzlich und zusammen
mit dem kinderzuschlag sind das 1,365
milliarden euro in diesem jahr auf 2,3
millionen kinder nicht
und deshalb steckt in den entlastungs
paket neben dem heizkostenzuschuss und
dem neuen euro ticket speziell auch für
familien der 100 euro kinderbonus
zusätzlich weil wir eben wissen wieviel
lasten gerade familien jetzt und in den
kronen monaten zu tragen haben so nehmen
wir gemeinsam druck aus dem kessel das
ist bitter nötig
sie wissen mein ziel als
familienministerin geht aber darüber
hinaus ich will familie mit der
kindergrundsicherung ebenso konkret
finanziell unterstützen durch einen
höheren garantiebetrag für alle durch
stärkere förderung einkommensschwacher
familien und alle förderleistungen
werden gebündelt damit sie dann wirklich
alle kinder erreicht ohne bürokratische
antrags wege das ist
und heute machen wir da zusätzlich für
alle kinder und jugendlichen diesen der
pandemie besonders schwer hatten mit dem
aktionsprogramm aufholen nach verona
durch zusätzliche 272 millionen euro
zusätzlich unterstützung auch diese
stehen diesem jahr zur verfügung ganz
herzlichen dank auch dafür
[Applaus]
zweitens investiert man haus in die
zukunft von frauen noch nie hatten wir
so viele gut ausgebildete frauen mit so
guten abschlüssen der faz titelte vor
einer woche im wirtschaftsteil die
personal und not kommt mit wucht der
fachkräftemangel verschärft sich
dramatisch aber ein wesentlicher teil
der lösung ist dass frauen mit kindern
der erwerbstätigkeit einfach erleichtert
wird meine damen und herren die
vereinbarkeit von familie und beruf wie
darf eben keine mutprobe mehr sein und
erst recht keine herausforderung für die
gesundheit und deswegen fördern wir
unter anderem die vereinbarkeit mit dem
elterngeld diese bekannteste und
beliebteste familienleistung in
deutschland ist uns jeden einzelnen der
77 milliarden euro wert weil es
youtube und später beruf und familie
tatsächlich unter einen hut zu bekommen
drittens wir haben wir den nächsten
monaten verstärkt für den zukunftsberuf
pflege wir wollen mehr frauen und männer
für diesen beruf gewinnen und damit
reagieren wir auch die herausforderungen
auch unsere alternde gesellschaft
viertens investieren wir in die
perspektive der krebs geflüchteten aus
der ukraine wir wissen alle 80 prozent
sind frauen etwa 40 prozent sind
minderjährig gegeben dafür rund 1 31
millionen euro für mehr tomaten haben im
zusammenhang mit dem krieg in der
ukraine aus und mit diesem geld
finanzieren wir kinderbetreuung parallel
zu integrationskursen wir helfen
schwangeren frauen über die stiftung
mutter und kind und wir fördern das
patenschaftsprogramm menschen stärken
menschen das ist wirklich gut angelegtes
geld
damit diese menschen eine perspektive
haben und hier auch tatsächlich gut
ankommen können fünftes beispiel für
gute investitionen wir investieren in
die zukunft unserer demokratie meine
damen und herren das bundesweit größte
programm zur demokratieförderung die
vielfalt gestaltung und extremismus
prävention es heißt nicht umsonst
demokratie leben wir starten das aus mit
robusten 165 millionen euro denn es gibt
viel demokratie zu leben in diesem land
wir fördern mit diesem bundesprogramm
demokratie leben mehr als 600
initiativen in deutschland die sich
gegen menschenfeindlichkeit und
rassismus und für toleranz und
demokratie
engagieren
meine damen und herren wie robust und
widerstandsfähig unsere gesellschaft
gegenüber äußeren krisen ist das bemisst
sich an ihrer stärke im inneren darin
investiert das bfs agiert
wir ermöglichen frauen der
erwerbstätigkeit wir stärken familien
wir unterstützen kinder und jugendliche
wir reagieren auf die herausforderungen
einer alternden gesellschaft für fördern
engagement und damit den zusammenhalt
und genau damit machen wir dort schon
stark herzlichen dank
lisa paus war dass die
bundesfamilienministerin
und es ist auch noch mal deutlich
geworden dass ja auch ihr etat
gekennzeichnet ist das was hier den
bundeshaushalt kennzeichnet nämlich die
folgen der korona pandemie und auch die
folgen des ukraine krieges gary und
bäumen für die fdp werden frau beier
ihre erwartung in die rede die wir
gerade gehört haben haben sie vor kaum
erfüllt würde ich mal sagen was wir hier
von der familienministerin gehört haben
ist ein eindrucksvoller beleg dafür in
welchem paralleluniversum man dort lebt
von den rund 500 milliarden euro im
bundeshaushalt sind für das
familienministerium knapp 13 milliarden
euro vorgesehen also noch nicht einmal 3
mit dieser kümmerlichen ausgabenplanung
belegen sie hier erneut eine
himmelschreiende ignoranz der echten
probleme unserer familie
anfang des monats von wir auf ein
trauriges jubiläum hingewiesen seit
nunmehr 50 jahren sterben in diesem land
mehr menschen als neue geboren werden
das defizit betrug im letzten jahr
228.000 geburten ein einmaliger
nachkriegsrekord
angesichts dieser demographischen
katastrophe müsse man sofort zu einem
massiven familienprogramm kommt ein
willkommenes programm wie wir es seit
mehreren jahren fordern
planung in diese richtung fehlanzeige
das wäre ja recht
stattdessen will man die ausgaben für
maßnahmen zur stärkung der vielfalt
toleranz und demokratie wie oft haben
wir das heute schon gehört drastisch
erhöhen nämlich von über 150 millionen
euro im letzten jahr um sage und
schreibe 22 prozent auf nunmehr 1 183
einhalb millionen euro in diesem jahr
vielfalt toleranz demokratie das hört
sich ja eigentlich ganz gut an
eigentlich sogar klasse ich denke da an
unsere regionale vielfalt eine tragende
säule unseres föderalen systems nehmen
sie die maske gerne wieder auf ich denke
an die toleranz gegenüber
andersdenkenden die angesichts der
einigkeit politischen denkens dringend
der förderung bedarf und ich denke an
das demokratische grundprinzip von
wahlen und abstimmungen
hier muss unbedingt die bereitschaft der
mehrheit gefördert werden die minderheit
nicht nur zu tolerieren sondern auch zu
schützen
aber ich denke auch daran dass die
gesellschaft ma nich mehr und mehr in
gut und böse geteilt wird dass teile der
hier erst seit kurzen leben denn eigenen
gesetzen und werden folgen die mit
enormen unseres grundgesetzes nicht
selten massiv kollidieren also
aufgaben ohne ende förderung fehlanzeige
schauen wir doch einmal näher in das
bundesprogramm demokratie leben auch das
hört sich gut an aber auch bei genauer
betrachtung wiederum abgründe tun sich
auf das bundesamt für verfassungsschutz
hat in seinem letzten bericht hat
zugleich viel extremisten an der
politischen an den politischen rändern
gezielt nämlich
33.300 auf rechter seite und
34.300 auf linker seite also sind beide
seiten noch etwa gleich stark vertreten
wobei
bei 1092 rechten gewalttaten 1237 linke
gewalttaten zu verzeichnen sind auf
dieser grundlage ergibt sich eine
bemerkenswerte schieflage des
förderprogramms denn es stehen nur fünf
modellprojekte gegen linksextremismus
21 modellprojekten gegen
rechtsextremismus gegenüber
aus diesem jahr das ist vielleicht ihrer
ansicht aber das ist ein ungleichgewicht
was wo der änderung bedarf aus diesem
abschlussbericht erfahren dass man sich
zu fast zwei dritteln mit rechtsextremen
orientierungen und handlungen befasste
ein porno zum linksextremismus fehlte
das ist nicht das dritte was übrig
bleibt sondern dass fehlte völlig ja
schlimmer aber noch seinerzeit hatte die
ehemalige bundesministerin kristina
schröder die förderungen eine
selbstverständlichkeit geknüpft nämlich
die gefördert mussten sich seinerzeit
zur freiheitlich demokratischen
grundordnung bekennen eine sogenannte
extremismusklausel
aber schon anfang 2013 hat manuela
schwesig diese klausel ersatzlos
gestrichen bei dieser skandalösen
streichung ist es bis heute geblieben
das ist das einfallstor durch das seit
jahren die sogenannte antifa die der
verfassungsschutz fast zur hälfte dem
linksextremismus zuordnet an die
futtertröge staatlicher förderung
gelangt auch keine abhilfe
auf eine abhilfe dürfen wir künftig wohl
nicht hoffen
bekanntlich ist die oberste
verfassungsschützer rinnen die ihren
minister ich hatte ja auch ein
familienprogramm abgestellt hören sie
doch besser zu bekanntlich ist die
oberste verfassungsschützer in die
innenministerin ja nicht gerade
zurückhaltend wenn es darum geht ihre
ansichten in einem hand tv-magazin zu
publizieren und der parlamentarische
staatssekretär in unserem
familienministerium heißt wenn die man
ist ja heute dankenswerter da pflichtet
ihr darin auch noch bei
meine damen und herren diese regierung
hat eine extremismus problem das linke
auge verdeckt man mit einer dicken roten
klappe und sagt dann auch mit dem
anderen auge beherrschen war natürlich
das räumliche sehen
machen sie sich doch endlich einmal
ehrlich das programm sollte besser
antifa und kommunisten fördern heißen
oder aber es sollte wirklich der
demokratie diene aber dann läge können
sie bis zum ende
vielen dank
diese dank für die aufmerksamkeit
unser kollege sind gerichts hat jetzt
das wort für die spd-fraktion
und erst der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der spd fraktion
frau präsidentin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen meine
damen und herren
vor weg zum thema demokratie förderung
das gegeneinander aufrechnen von
linksdemokraten
linksextremistischen
von links links
von linksextremistischen straftaten
gegenüber den rechtsextremistischen
straftaten und die gleichsetzung dieser
ist ein wirklicher eine eine ohrfeige
der hinterbliebenen der zahlreichen
opfer der rechtsextremistische gewalt in
diesem land
denn die anzahl derer die richtige opfer
und tode tod sogar
gestorben sind das sind diejenigen das
ist der grund weil es unserem leben von
menschen geht es ist der grund warum der
demokratie förderung betreiben
extremismus bekämpfen und das vor allem
dem gegen rechts vor allen dingen gegen
rechts ein menschenleben ist was wert
und deshalb ist es richtig und wichtig
dass wir das demokratie fördergesetz
bekommen und lieber kollege lérida wir
haben ja bis vor kurzem auch gemeinsam
regiert und es gibt auch einen
gemeinsamen entwurf damals noch
innenminister seehofer und unserer
familienministerin hat unsere damaligen
familienministerin zum demokratie
fordern gesetzt warum jetzt auf einmal
eine distanzierung des eigenen gegenüber
dem eigenen minister seehofer weiß ja
nicht mehr da muss man das ja nicht mehr
richtig finden das finde ich sehr sehr
bedauerlich denn die erkenntnis war bei
der union schon mal besser lieber
kollegin hier wieder
die ministerin hat dankenswerterweise
noch mal deutlich gemacht wie viele in
diesem haushalt steckt hilfen für
familien sofort zuschlag kinderzuschlag
wir haben den 100 euro bonus jetzt noch
mal mit dabei elterngeld als wirklich
attraktivste leistung mit unserem
programm aber auch noch mal zusätzlich
durch die haushaltsberatungen
jugendmagazins die jugend
migrationsdienst gestärkt
programme gegen rechtsextremismus
gestärkt und hilfen für geflüchtete
insbesondere aus der ukraine
all das
ist in diesem haushalt mit drin und
dafür ganz herzlichen dank den
haushältern aber auch ganz herzlichen
dank für den entwurf den das parlament
jetzt noch ein bisschen besser gemacht
hat
und dann kam die bemerkung es gibt dann
einfach so die kollegin bea hatte das
gerade nochmal gebracht ich wäre ja froh
wenn all die ansätze der union was jetzt
kritisiert wird was angeblich zu spät
kommt oder noch gar nicht kommt in der
regierungszeit mal dagewesen wäre jetzt
vorzuwerfen dass nach ein paar hundert
tagen noch nicht alle maßnahmen bei der
elterngeld reform bei der kita form und
beim und bei allen anderen
kindergrundsicherung da sind dass wir
werden ja dankbar wenn wir das mit euch
jetzt mal umsetzen können aber ihr habt
es damals in der alten regierung
blockiert
aber wir wissen aber wir wissen aber wir
wissen aber liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen dass die zukünftigen haushälter
der haushalte mit all dem was wir im
koalitionsvertrag stehen haben natürlich
schwierig zu gestalten werden denn die
herausforderungen bleiben ja da und all
das was im koalitionsvertrag steht soll
auch umgesetzt werden und deshalb eine
ein aktueller hinweis dass wir jetzt ein
sondervermögen was insbesondere von der
linksfraktion hat ja so heftig
kritisiert wird für die bundeswehr
einrichten weil wir es richtig finden
dass unsere bundeswehr auch angesichts
der sich veränderten internationalen
lage vernünftig aus stärker aufstellen
muss das ist ein vorteil für die zukunft
das ist ein vorteil für die zukünftigen
haushalte weil eben das geld nicht zu
lasten der anderen haushalte geht
sondern im gegenteil es gibt an der
extra haushalt und dadurch sind all die
projekte kindergrundsicherung hinter
reform auch deshalb eher gesichert als
geschwächt und das ist die wahrheit
liebe kollegin
und wir haben mit kindergrundsicherung
noch was wichtiges vor sie haben es
erwähnt wir haben die ersten schritte
getan jetzt wohl jetzt gibt es eine eine
interfraktionelle oder an der
interministerielle arbeitsgruppe das
finde ich richtig dass die
bundesregierung nicht sagte dass es
ausschließlich aufgabe des von
mindestens 9 die kindergrundsicherung
ist nämlich nicht einfach nur eine
finanzielle leistungen die wir auszahlen
wollen sondern wir wollen damit
erreichen wie gesagt mehreren sollen
auch erreichen nicht nur das werk über
kinderarmut schützen nein wir wollen es
auch noch gericht gestalten einen
grundbeitrag haben und wir wollen
zusätzlich eine zweite säule einführen
dass wir sagen diejenigen die in besser
verdienende familien wohnen dann eben
entsprechend weniger bekommen und die
anderen entsprechend mehr das ist auch
noch sozial gerecht ausgestattet wir
wollen es vereinfachen das system die
familienleistung sollen zusammengelegt
werden und wenn wir das in angriff
nehmen und ich finde das gut es wird
jetzt in angriff genommen dann werden
wir auch wirklich den richtigen schritt
zur absicherung von familien erreicht
herzlichen dank für die aufmerksamkeit
sönke rix war das für die spd fraktion
ja und einen zeitplan für die
kindergrundsicherung den hat die
ministerin schon in diesen 100 mal
skizziert das ist ihr ziel sei dass im
nächsten jahr ein gesetzentwurf dazu
gebe und dass man bis zum ende der
legislaturperiode dann das beschließen
dann auszahlen könnte das würde dann
bedeuten dass spätestens 2025
in deutschland aus über 40 prozent der
alleinerziehenden leben in armut oder
sind von armut gefährdet sie brauchen
dringend mehr unterstützung vom bund die
bisherigen bundesregierung allen voran
die cdu csu haben die lage der
alleinerziehenden über jahrzehnte hinweg
in unserer gesellschaft ignoriert die
ampelkoalition weigert sich ebenfalls
dringend notwendige maßnahmen für
alleinerziehende einzuleiten die
anrechnung des kindergeldes auf den
unterhaltsvorschuss würde hier helfen
aktuell wird das kindergeld vollständig
mit dem unterhaltsvorschuss verrechnet
bei übung vom kindergeld sinkt der
unterhaltsvorschuss entsprechend wir
fordern daher dass das kindergeld nur
zur hälfte auf den unterhaltsvorschuss
angerechnet wird
von dieser maßnahme würden nun 850
850.000 kinder in alleinerziehenden
familien profitieren durch diese
änderung würden sie 110 euro mehr im
monat zur verfügung haben
110 euro sind mindestens ein
wocheneinkauf an lebensmittel neue
schulsachen sportschuhe oder die
mitgliedschaft in einem verein außerdem
wäre es sinnvoll hier die bedarfsprüfung
ab 12 jahren abzuschaffen hierdurch
könnten rund eine million kinder und
deren eltern dauerhaft entlastet werden
die gesamtausgaben für den punkt würden
sich durch diese maßnahmen um etwa zwei
milliarden euro jährlich erhöhen also
nur ein bruchteil davon was die ampel
und die union bereit sind für die
bundeswehr aus zu geben glaubt im
koalitionsvertrag möchte die
bundesregierung allein erziehende
mittels einer steuergutschrift entlasten
steuergutschriften bringen jedoch den
wenigsten allein erziehenden etwas weil
die meisten kaum erwerbseinkommen haben
und auf transferleistungen angewiesen
sind durch die aktuelle steigen die
inflation sind alleinerziehende
zusätzlich massiv von armut bedroht die
ampel koalition muss jetzt muss jetzt
handeln und verhindern dass noch mehr
alleine ziehen die ihn in die armut
abrutschen ihr maßnahmenmix bisher ist
völlig unzureichend konsequenter kampf
gegen kinderarmut sieht anders aus
vielen dank
für die fdp fraktion spricht der kollege
martin graß märz
[Applaus]
hatte frau präsidentin meine damen und
herren ich bin stolz auf die
verbesserung die sich die fortschritts
koalition vorgenommen hat um den
reformstau in der familienpolitik an
anzugehen endlich werden die
rahmenbedingungen an die realität
angepasst wie menschen auf vielfältige
weise in deutschland gemeinsam familie
sind die nachschärfung und ergänzungen
die wir für den haushalt 2022 heute
gegenüber dem entwurf der
vorgängerregierung vornehmen sind
insbesondere den zwei großen themen der
zeit geschuldet der korona pandemie und
dem auswirkungen des totalen krieges den
russland über die ukraine gebracht hat
die interessen von familien sind in der
pandemie oft zurückgestellt worden für
kinder und jugendliche war die zeit
besonders hart unterricht nur auf
distanz ein schüleraustausch war nicht
möglich das erste engagement im verein
hat nicht stattgefunden freunde durften
sich nicht sehen lebenswege und
möglichkeiten für die zukunft eben
versperrt von der zunahme psychischer
erkrankungen ganz zu schweigen
es gelingt uns 272 millionen euro
einzusetzen wo ein aufholen der
entstandenen lücken zu unterstützen da
von diesen 40 millionen euro in den
kinder- und jugendplan und 60 millionen
in die sprach kitas die bundesstiftung
frühe hilfen erhält zusätzlich 35
millionen euro und fördert damit die
psychosoziale betreuung von familien in
denen gerade die kleinsten besondere
unterstützung bedürfen sie ermöglichen
40 millionen euro für die familien
ferienzeiten stärken die kinder und
jugendstiftung mit rund 80 millionen
euro an möglichen der deutschen stiftung
für engagement und ehrenamt ein mittel
auf wuchs um zehn millionen euro in
diesen zusätzlichen herausforderungen
unserer zeit sind wir auf eine starke
gesellschaft angewiesen die von starken
bürgerinnen und bürgern getragen wird
mit der aufstockung der programme
menschen stärken menschen und demokratie
leben fördern wir den zusammenhalt in
der gesellschaft und unterstützen
programme zur prävention und gegen
extremismus
wir unterstützen das unermüdliche
engagement in der aufnahme der vielen
geflüchteten die bei uns schutz suchen
den vielen freiwilligen möchte ich an
dieser stelle noch einmal ausdrücklich
danken
wir zusätzlich auch den hinweis dass
hilfsbereitschaft weiterhin dringend
gebraucht wird und jene die inzwischen
seit monaten beinahe übermenschliches
leisten unverändert dankbar für weitere
unterstützung sind
diese aufgaben sind enorm gerade weil
unter denen die wir auch nehmen so viele
kinder sind sie brauchen ein gefühl von
willkommen sein und hoffnung das geht
nur gemeinsam mit der zivilgesellschaft
die mit sport kultur und gemeinschaft
viel zeit dazu beiträgt dass diese
kinder wieder lachen können mit 16
millionen euro unterstützen wir
maßnahmen für geflüchtete darunter auch
psychosoziale zentren nicht zu vergessen
sind unsere familienrecht rechtlichen
maßnahmen die im haushalt nicht wirksam
werden aber dennoch große fortschritte
und verbesserungen für unsere
gesellschaft bedeuten zum beispiel die
abschaffung des paragraphen 219 a die
ermöglichung der mehr elternschaft die
liberalisierung des namensrechts oder
die möglichkeit ohne entwürdigungen im
verfahren den geschlechts eintrag in
person personenstandsregister anzupassen
weitere projekte haben wir bereits im
blick noch müssen jugendliche in
stationären einrichtungen einen großen
anteil ihres eigenen verdienstes für die
unterbringung abgeben wir werden denen
die sich anstrengen und die ersten
stufen auf ihre persönlichen aufstiegs
leiter erklimmen
rückenwind geben statt signale zu setzen
eigene mühen würden sich nicht lohnen
deshalb soll die kostenbeteiligung zügig
ganz entfallen
außerdem setzen wir uns dafür ein mehr
menschen mehr finanzielle unterstützung
bei einer kinderwunschbehandlung zu
ermöglichen es ist grausam wenn wünsche
nach einem eigenen kind am geldbeutel
der eltern scheitern müssen wenn zu
deren erfüllung medizinische
unterstützung notwendig ist die realität
von familie ist heute eine andere als
gestern
darauf müssen wir reagieren und stellen
uns dieser aufgabe vielen dank
martin gassner herz war das für die fdp
fraktion ja sehr viele projekte die sich
die ampel in diesem bereich vorgenommen
hat er hat noch mal einige aufgezählt zu
für die zukunft nicht nur was ich jetzt
in diesem haushalt abbildet hermann
josef tebroke für die union jetzt
damen und herren herzlich kann noch
nicht erkennen dass der vorgelegte
haushalt tatsächlich ein fortschritt
sein soll und ich bin mir auch nicht
ganz sicher die projekte die sie da
angekündigt haben wirklich unserer
gesellschaft ein fortschritt sein werden
aber das werden wir den zukünftigen
debatten sicherlich ausführlich erörtern
meine damen und herren mit dem
vorliegenden einzelplan und dem
gesamthaushalt insgesamt beraten wir die
finanziellen grundlagen einer politik
für jugend frauen senioren und eben auch
für familie und darauf möchte ich
fokussieren meine damen und herren
familienpolitik richtet sich wenn sie so
wollen an die keimzelle der gesellschaft
jedenfalls geht es um die kleine einheit
die nach unserer auffassung so
vielfältig ausgestaltet sein kann in der
menschen füreinander verantwortung
übernehmen
im rahmen einer engen persönlichen
insbesondere verwandtschaftlichen
beziehungen auf dauer
verbindlich
generationenübergreifend und
insbesondere als gemeinschaft mit
kindern und familien zumal mit kindern
leisten einen wichtigen generativen
beitrag das hat zuletzt das
bundesverfassungsgericht in seinem
aktuellen urteil zur notwendigkeit der
staffelung von
pflegeversicherungsbeiträgen anerkannt
ein erfolg gerade für kinderreiche
familien denen wir ausdrücklich begrüßen
wir gehen davon aus
wir gehen davon aus dass nunmehr auch
eine intensivere politische diskussion
nicht nur der renten- und
krankenversicherungsbeiträge sondern der
generativen beiträge zum sozialsystem
insgesamt erfolgt und werden uns daran
intensiv beteiligen familien zumal mit
kindern tragen eine besondere
finanzielle last dass es wiederholt ihr
aufgehoben worden kinder sind ein
geschenk familie und auch für unsere
gesellschaft aber sie dürfen nicht zu
einem armutsrisiko werden und sollen
möglichst unabhängig von den
wirtschaftlichen verhältnissen ihrer
eltern die gleichen guten
entwicklungschancen haben
vater staat es beteiligt aber er ist
nicht teil der familie erlebt von der
familie und darum ist es seine aufgabe
und ist auch aufgabe der gesellschaft
diese leistung in den familien
anzuerkennen und sie bei der wahrnehmung
dieser zugleich staatstragenden und den
einzelnen seine persönliche entfaltung
unterstützenden funktionen auch zu
unterstützen
familie braucht das haben wir wiederholt
aufgezeigt dazu zeitliche und
finanzielle
spielräume und die notwendige
infrastruktur
damit ist bildungs damit dass
familienpolitik familienpolitik immer
auch bildungspolitik sieht betreuungs
politik pflege gesundheitspolitik
sozialpolitik wohnungspolitik zeit
politik und eben auch mehr als
wirtschafts und beschäftigungspolitik
folgerichtig werden die
familienpolitischen maßnahmen und
entscheidungen auch gar nicht alle im
einzelplan 17 abgebildet der tatsächlich
gerade mal 13 milliarden umfasst sondern
den vielen anderen einzeln plänen im
haushalt insgesamt die entscheidende
frage aber hier ist werden der
vorliegenden haus ausgeladen und
insbesondere der einzelplan 17 dem
anliegen einer gerechten und umfassenden
familienpolitik gerecht lässt der
haushalt der ampel ein
familienpolitisches konzept erkennen
wieder ich widerspreche ihnen an dieser
stelle erhöhen wir können das nicht
erkennen
ist der haushalt den wenigsten
nachhaltig und generationengerecht
finanziert vorwarfen müssen sie haben da
dankenswerterweise sehr intensiv darauf
hingewiesen und die bedeutung auch eines
ausgeglichenen haushaltes für die
nachfolgende generation ich bin gespannt
und die vorsitze die sie formuliert
haben auch die gleichen sind die dann
die ampel verfolgen wird ich frage wir
fragen uns zu schlagen sich denn die
koalition koalitionsvertrag
angekündigten familienpolitischen
vorhaben nieder kindergrundsicherung das
gerade angekündigt wollen frau
ministerin peric sie haben das ebenfalls
angekündigt angekündigt ist aber noch
keine keine wirksame maßnahme gegen
kinderarmut wenn es darum geht dann
können sie auch die konstruktive
unterstützung der
unionsfraktion auf jeden fall ja
können sie auf jedenfalls setzen
ein anderes was uns sehr beschäftigt ist
die frage wie denn eigentlich der
haushalt der einzelplan auf die aktuell
gestiegenen herausforderungen für
familien reagiert corona ukrainische
flüchtlinge steigende preise wir meinen
absolut unzureichend wir haben immer
wieder darauf hingewiesen gefragten
gefordert dass die ampel die maßnahmen
ergreifen möchte ich bin froh handelt
dass die ampel auf einige hinweise
eingegangen ist gleichwohl glauben wir
dass an mindestens drei stellen noch
einmal nachgebessert werden könnte meine
kollegin hatte bereits darauf
hingewiesen sie haben die möglichkeiten
zum änderungsantrag zu folgen ich lade
sie ausdrücklich dazu ein
und nicht zuletzt warten wirklich
braucht auch das thema nicht mehr im
einzelnen einzugehen die unterstützung
für alleinerziehende ich weise darauf
hin bereits im april haben wir dazu
einen umfassenden antrag vorgelegt und
haben jetzt auch noch mal ein
entschließungsantrag vorbereitet der die
finanziellen voraussetzungen dafür
schafft dass auch bald diese notwendigen
maßnahmen ergriffen werden können wie
verdopplung des kinderbonus zum beispiel
und da eine erhöhung des
entlastungsbetrag es wenn sie das
genauso sehen wie wir das den
alleinerziehenden hilfe zuteil werden
sollte dann stimmt sie doch gerne
unserem entschließungsantrag zu
so wie uns das vorstellen meine damen
und herren das können sie sich
wiederholen deswegen werden wir ablehnen
ich danke für ihre aufmerksamkeit und
sicher auch für die kollegialität das
ist mit spricht die nächste rednerin ist
unsere kollegin im herbst für bündnis 90
die
grünen dann komplett identisch
sehr geehrte kolleginnen der
demokratischen fraktionen der ruf der
jungen menschen voraus alt ist manchmal
nicht ganz fair die jugend sei verwöhnt
und faul anspruchsvoll obwohl so
unerfahren und dann auch noch utopisch
idealistisch älteren menschen fehlt es
leider zu oft an verständnis für junge
lebensrealitäten und umgekehrt in einer
demokratischen gesellschaft sind aber
alle altersgruppen relevant für eine
ausgeglichene nachhaltige gestaltung
unseres miteinanders und
deshalb muss ich folgende worte aus
gegebenem anlass an den bundeskanzler
richten herscheid
sie sind auf dem katholikentag auf junge
engagierte menschen gestoßen die für den
klimaschutz auf die straße gehen sich
politisieren und bilden um für ihre
eigene zukunft und auch für unsere zu
kämpfen ihr umgang mit diesem jungen
menschen war mindestens schwierig und
daher möchte ich sie bitten ihre
äußerungen gegenüber diesen jungen
menschen richtig zu stellen und sich
gegebenenfalls zu entschuldigen denn was
auch immer sie sagen wollten die
geweckten assoziation wirken sowohl
geschichtsrevisionistische als
herabwürdigend für die junge
klimagerechtigkeit bewegung und
kontraproduktiv für unser gemeinsames
anliegen konsequenten klimaschutz
voranzubringen
die klimabewegung ist ein hervorragendes
beispiel für das worauf ich eigentlich
hin auswählen denn junge menschen sind
besser als ihr ruf jungsein es nicht nur
etwas unvollständiges auf dem weg zum
erwachsenwerden sondern hat ein recht
auf die eigene gegenwart und mitsprache
in der zukunftsgestaltung nicht etwa
trotz der widersprüche mit denen
vielleicht desillusionierten erwachsenen
sondern genau wegen ihrer anderen
perspektive ihren prioritäten und
idealen im dritten engagement bericht
des bfj gaben fast zwei drittel aller
jungen menschen an sich im vergangenen
jahr für einen gesellschaftlichen zweck
engagiert zu haben junges engagement ist
ein großer teil vom unsichtbaren kitt
unserer gesellschaft von dem so viele
immer sprechen
freiwilligendienste zum beispiel sind
eben nicht nur orientierungs jahre
sondern auch echte unterstützung und
einer der wichtigsten und schönsten
berührungspunkte der generation
deshalb sollten wir als ampel anders als
die vorgängerregierung ist eigentlich
vorgesehen hatte für die ausfinanzierung
der freiwilligendienste im laufenden
haushaltsjahr und wir erhöhen den etat
der jugendverbände und
jugendmigrationsdienst das sind nur ein
paar konkrete beispiele für den
grundstein den wir hier noch im
laufenden haushalt zu erleben wir wollen
die jugendpolitik neu aufleben lassen
wir wollen dafür sorgen dass allen
jugendlichen in ihrer orientierungsphase
die tür für einen freiwilligendienst
offensteht teilzeit option
digitalisierung taschengeld erhöhung
mehr stellen all das haben wir uns
vorgenommen
sehr geehrte kolleginnen
dieser haushalt legt einen guten
grundstein für unsere vorhaben aber klar
wird auch wir fangen gerade erst an und
meinen letzten satz möchte ich an die
jugendlichen hier auf den tribünen
richten schön dass ihr uns zuguckt bitte
bleibt laut frech und engagiert wir
stehen an eurer seite
emilia fester war das für den ist 90 die
grünen und ja nicht nur zum haushalt
sondern auch eine aufforderung an urlaub
scholz der die nicht gehört haben dürfte
denn der sitzt gleich wie sie sehen im
vorschaufenster in brüssel bei einer
pressekonferenz zum abschluss des
eu-gipfels also immer fest der bibliser
neubauer übrigens die klimaaktivisten
die urlaubs scholz vorgeworfen hat dass
er beim katholikentag klimaaktivisten
mit nazis verglichen hatte haben soll
die regierungssprecherin übrigens
christiane hoffmann bier hat diesen
vorwurf zurückgewiesen in dieser woche
als vollkommen absurd
dass die hartnäckigkeit meines ersten
juso-vorsitzenden rufen blieb ich dabei
und würde ohne seine arbeit heute
vielleicht auch gar nicht verstehen
warum liebe ich dort nun weil die
jugendorganisation der demokratischen
parteien mehr sind als plakatkleber
drucken sie sind eine essentielle naht
zwischen jungen menschen und parteien
dort wird diskutiert dort wird
gestritten dort lernt sich junge
menschen aus der ganzen republik und
manchmal sogar aus der ganzen welt
kennen kurzum es sind orte der
bildungsarbeit unter beteiligung
und insbesondere in zeiten in denen das
vertrauen und zutrauen junger menschen
in parteien permanent schwindet brauchen
wir die jugendorganisationen und ihre
wichtige arbeit und es macht mich daher
unendlich stolz eine bundeshaushalt zu
stimmen zu dürfen der diese aufgabe und
verantwortung erkennt und die
jugendorganisation mit 4,2 millionen
euro unterstützt denn auch das ist eine
frage des respekts nicht nur zu sagen
toll was ihr da macht sondern auch zu
sagen wir unterstützen euch bei dem was
ihr da macht weil im haushalt mit seinen
vielen zahlen immer wahnsinnig anonym
wird möchte ich es ganz konkret machen
diese 4,2 millionen euro helfen unter
anderem noah und erinnert den aktuellen
juso-vorsitzenden in mainz bin weiterhin
andere junge menschen für politik zu
begeistern
und ich danke ihnen und all den anderen
jungen menschen die in ihrer freizeit
andere für politik begeistern für die
arbeit die sie tagtäglich leisten
die stärkung von demokratie ist aber
nicht die alleinige aufgabe von parteien
und so steckt hinter dem titel ausgaben
zur stärkung von vielfalt toleranz und
demokratie ein breit gefächerter strauß
an maßnahmen projekten und programmen
die durch die zivilgesellschaft getragen
werden allen voran natürlich das projekt
der das programm demokratie leben mit
mehr als 500 projekten in ganz
deutschland 16 landes demokratie zentren
320 lokalen partnerschaften für
demokratie und 150 modellprojekte und
weil ein haushalt ich habe es eben schon
erwähnt nie eine seelenlose zusammen
zahlen sammlung sein sollte möchte ich
ihnen eines dieser geförderten
modellprojekte vorstellen vielleicht
hilft das auch dazu bei einigen hier die
akzeptanz für dieses programm doch noch
etwas zu erhöhen das projekt wer traum
des vereins werkzeug in mainz entwickelt
maßnahmen für inhaftierte und menschen
in der bewährungshilfe um
radikalisierung im bereich des
politischen und religiösen extremismus
zu verhindern
nun mag der zuschuss von 250.000 euro im
jahr 2022 an werkzeug im vergleich zum
gesamtvolumen des programms demokratie
leben recht gering wirken aber auch mit
dieser summe sorgen wir dafür dass
inhaftierten menschen in rheinland pfalz
eine perspektive aufgezeigt werden kann
jenseits von hass und gewalt liegt und
wenn sie liebe kolleginnen und liebe
kollegen auf der programm homepage
recherchieren dann werden sie
feststellen demokratie leben leistet
auch in ihren wahlkreisen verdammt
wichtige arbeit die wir hier alle
dankbar sein
aber auch ein anderer stelle wird
wichtige arbeit geleistet die respekt
coaches setzten sich bundesweit an
schulen für demokratische werte ein
unterschiedliche meinungen akzeptieren
position beziehen argumentieren wie es
auf der homepage heißt dinge die wir
hier in diesem parlament aber auch in
vielen anderen bereichen unseres lebens
tagtäglich tun und bei denen es gut und
richtig ist sich früh zu erlernen als
lehrer weiß ich wie schwierig es
manchmal ist veranstaltungen und
projekttage neben dem regulären
unterricht zu organisieren denn die
nötige vorbereitung brot zwischen
klassenarbeiten mündlichen noten und dem
abarbeiten des lehrplans oftmals auf der
strecke zu bleiben deshalb braucht es
auch außerschulische angebote und
unterstützung und es war deshalb absolut
richtig die haushaltsmittel im
parlamentarischen verfahren noch einmal
um 15 millionen euro zu erhöhen im
ergebnis werden die respekt coaches
jetzt mit 36 millionen euro gefördert
und spricht unser haushalt darin wie
elisabeth kaiser natürlich auch
ausdrücklich danke für ihren einsatz für
dieses projekt
denn meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren prävention gegen jede form von
extremismus rassismus und
gruppenbezogener menschenfeindlichkeit
kann der erste schritt sein selbst aktiv
zu werden selbst aktiv zu werden bei
themen wie toleranz vielfalt respekt und
demokratie und wer weiß wie viele junge
menschen durch sie respekt coaches ihrem
weg zu einer jugendorganisation finden
und in einigen jahren vielleicht sogar
selbst hier den weg in den deutschen
bundestag ich würde es mir wünschen
vielen herzlichen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
sagt daniel baldi für die spd fraktion
er sitzt im familienausschuss
nicht rednerin besitzt für ihre fraktion
im familienausschuss für die cdu csu
fraktion das ist astrid timmermann
fechter
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren der
einzelplan 17 aus dem geschäftsbereich
des ministeriums für familie senioren
frauen und jugend ist mit seinen 12,6
milliarden euro im verhältnis zu anderen
einzelplänen ein ziemlich kleiner aber
gemessen an seiner bedeutung ein
ausserordentlicher großer posten im
bundeshaushalt
er macht nur 2,5 prozent des
gesamthaushalts aus betrifft aber 100
prozent der deutschen bevölkerung etwa
50 prozent sind frauen 49 prozent sind
männer davon sind 22 prozent senioren
und rund zehn prozent sind jugendliche
aber jeder einzelne von uns ist eine
familie man kann also sagen unser
haushalt geht jeden etwas an da
verwundert es umso mehr dass die gruppe
der seniorinnen und senioren
immerhin ein fünftel der
gesamtbevölkerung und sogar namentlich
im titel erwähnt im haushalt der ampel
regierung so stiefmütterlich behandelt
wird immerhin handelt es sich in teilen
auch um die generation die unser land
nach dem krieg wieder aufgebaut und zu
wohlstand gebracht hat den wir also alle
viel zu verdanken haben
da verwundert es auch dass die regierung
die haushaltsmittel für die arbeit der
seniorenpolitik in 2022 auf dem niveau
von 2021 einfach nur fortschreibt es
werden natürlich seniorenpolitische
projekte finanziert zb um demografische
veränderungen und das lebensumfeld
gemeinsam zu gestalten und mit wirkung
auf lokaler ebene zu stärken es stehen
auf haushaltsmittel zur verfügung um
gute rahmenbedingungen für die familie
friede zu schaffen und die teilhabe
älterer menschen zu ermöglichen
was in diesem haushalt jedoch nur am
rande behandelt wird ist ein großes
gesellschaftliches thema der letzten
jahre wenn nicht sogar das größte
gesellschaftliche thema der letzten
jahre weil es durch bewohner an relevanz
gewonnen hat es geht um das thema
einsamkeit deren auswirkungen und der
umgang mit ihr bestimmten in den letzten
jahren zu recht die öffentliche
diskussion
viele menschen leiden unter einsamkeit
oder sozialer isolation mit
weitreichenden auswirkungen auf den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt und das
gesundheitswesen die gesundheitlichen
folgen umfassen neben psychischen folgen
wie zum beispiel stress
angsterkrankungen depressionen oder
demenz auch physische folgen wie zum
beispiel eine höhere anfälligkeit für
infektionen und
herz-kreislauf-erkrankungen oder auch
fehlernährung
vereinsamung macht also krank einsamkeit
betrifft alle generationen besonders
stark betroffen sind jedoch die jungen
erwachsenen und die hochaltrigen
seniorinnen und senioren
eine erfolgreiche strategie gegen
einsamkeit muss deshalb darin bestehen
menschen bis hin zur alter dabei zu
unterstützen selbstbestimmt zu leben und
an der gesellschaft teilzuhaben wir
müssen die forschung intensivieren
programme auflegen und neue konzepte für
eine aktive mitwirkung am
gesellschaftlichen leben entwickeln
dazu union sehen welche weitreichenden
folgen einsamkeit haben kann wir haben
diesbezüglich ein positionspapier
entwickelt mit dem titel gemeinsam gegen
einsamkeit für eine nationale strategie
und dort maßnahmen festgehalten es gibt
also auch in bezug auf das thema
einsamkeit noch viel zu tun ich bin
jedenfalls schon sehr gespannt auf die
einsamkeit strategie die anfang des
jahres von der ehemaligen ministerin
eine spiegel angekündigt wurde das
kompetenznetzwerk einsamkeit hat ja
seine arbeit im februar aufgenommen und
hilft ihnen sicherlich da nur eine
strategie zu entwickeln
ganz entscheidend ist dabei aber eine
auskömmliche finanzierung um einsamkeit
zu vermeiden und diese finanzierung
spielt sich leider in ihrem aktuellen
haushalt noch nicht wieder herzlichen
dank
[Applaus]
oracle spricht jetzt für die spd
fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin frau
ministerin kollegen kolleginnen kinder
und jugendliche sind unsere zukunft und
darum gehören sie immer ins zentrum
unserer politik seit mehr als zwei
jahren sind wir nun im krisenmodus und
haben sie nicht immer genug
berücksichtigt das sage ich durchaus
selbstkritisch der kollege sparen hat zu
beginn der pandemie einmal gesagt wir
würden uns später fiel verzeihen müssen
die frage ist ob unsere kinder uns
verzeihen können die gesparten
spielplätze die geschlossenen schulen
und kitas werden büros und geschäfte
zunächst ausgeblieben dieser umgang mit
der pandemie hat für kinder und
jugendliche folgen die wir gerade erst
beginnen aufzuarbeiten
wissenschaftliche studien unterstreichen
dies ich nenne hier exemplarisch die
cops ii studie zu psychischen gesundheit
in der pandemie am hamburger
universitätsklinikum und die kids co
erhebung zum kinderschutz des deutschen
jugendinstituts in münchen fast jedes
dritte kind leidet nach beginn der
pandemie unter psychischen
auffälligkeiten betroffen sind vor allem
kinder und jugendliche aus armen
familien
der angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine hat
eine neue fluchtbewegung ausgelöst im
letzten vierteljahr sind etwa 800.000
menschen aus der ukraine nach
deutschland gekommen vorwiegend frauen
kinder und jugendliche viele geflüchtete
zeigen großes interesse an
integrationskursen
berufliche orientierung und wollen in
schulen und kitas ankommen vor diesem
hintergrund bin ich sehr froh dass wir
in den verhandlungen zum haushalt 2022
geld dahin geben konnten wo es zu krisen
bearbeitung gebraucht wird zu erhalten
nach 12 so erhalten die jugendverbände
drei millionen euro zusätzlich um die
folgen der pandemie etwas abzufedern und
wieder kinder und jugendliche die
jugendarbeit zu begeistern denn die
zyklen sind kurz wer mit 16 jahren nicht
die gelegenheit hatte in der
mädchengruppe im alpenverein oder im
naturschutz im engagement und
verantwortung hineinzuwachsen wird das
mit 18 nicht einfach nach oben großartig
dass sie so viele jugendverbände diesen
anstellungen stellen und gut das ist
dafür finanzielle unterstützung geben
und gut ist es auch die beratungs und
unterstützungsstrukturen für geflüchtete
junge menschen zu stärken die jugend
migrationsdienst leisten sagt lilian
vorbildliche arbeit aber zur wahrheit
gehört auch sie sind seit langem am
limit und völlig unterfinanziert während
der finanzkrise kamen viele junge
südeuropäerinnen nach deutschland und
brauchten ihre unterstützung später
waren es syrische irakischen und
afghanischen geflüchtete inzwischen
junge menschen aus der ukraine
jetzt kann ein aufwuchs von acht
millionen euro wenigstens die spitzen
abfedern kaum ein bereich der
jugendsozialarbeit bringt so schnelle
und greifbare ergebnisse wie die arbeit
des migrationsdienstes sie trat betreuen
sind großen teilen hoch motivierte und
engagierte junge menschen die
unterstützung brauchen um sich hier gut
zurecht zu finden jeder euro ist hier
gut angelegt
kinder und jugendliche brauchen
förderung und bildung gemeinschaft und
vorbilder damit sie sich für demokratie
und gesellschaft begeistern können all
das bietet zum beispiel das genannte
programm des packages in diesem projekt
bearbeiten sozialpädagogische fachkräfte
mitschüler innen an mehr als 400 schulen
themen die respekt soziale ungleichheit
religion
demokratieverständnis oder auch aktuell
zum ukraine kick ich bin sehr
erleichtert dass die zusätzlichen 15
millionen euro die der
kabinettsausschuss zur bekämpfung von
rechtsextremismus und rassismus zugesagt
hatte jetzt auch 2022 wieder zur
verfügung stehen darum vielen dank an
unsere haushälterinnen für diese guten
nachrichten aber auch für den haushalt
2023 gilt kinder und jugendliche dürfen
wir nicht aus dem blick verlieren
denn was wir an ihnen versäumen kann
kaum wieder nachgeholt werden vielen
dank
ulrike bahr war das für die
sozialdemokraten die vorsitzende des
familienausschusses
ja und auch wenn in dieser woche über
den haushalt 2022 beschlossen wird
beraten und beschlossen wird der
haushalt 2023 der wird ja auch in diesem
jahr dennoch gelesen liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen mit diesem haushaltsentwurf
für das bundesministerium für familie
senioren frauen und jugend tun sie so
als ob das wirklich der ganz ganz große
wurf wäre nicht nur wegen der 12,6
milliarden sondern angeblich auch wegen
der inhalte jetzt mag 12,6 milliarden
erstmal nach einer guten nachricht
klingen aber wenn man bedenkt dass der
größte anteil im einzel 17 nämlich schon
86 prozent für fixe gesetzliche
leistungen vorgesehen ist da ist nicht
mehr viel spielraum und der spielraum
der da ist die nutzen sie eben leider
nicht
es ist auch darin dass die angekündigten
verbesserungen die es angeblich gibt
ganz bei familien ankommen das heißt die
familienpolitik der ampel existiert
quasi nicht und das hat man heute auch
beim reden diese ampel koalition auch
gemacht
und das in dieser koalition viel im
argen liegt hat man ja auch in den reden
gemacht aber das hat vielleicht wenn
auch unabsichtlich gleich mal die grünen
gewäsch dass sie haben sie uns an ihrer
seite frau fest der zerlegt den
bundeskanzler respekt also muss man auch
sagen so von wegen fortschritts
koalition und es läuft ist nicht viel
übrig und ist wendy schon beeindruckend
weil es geht hier einfach um menschen es
geht um familien es geht um jugend es
geht um frauen es geht um senioren und
sie zerstreiten sich nur dass es
wirklich nicht angemessen für unser land
und für alle die sie zuständig sind
sie machen sich in dem einzelplan noch
nicht mal die mühe zu differenzieren zu
schauen wo ist in unterschiedliche
dringlichkeiten wo sind unterschiedliche
bedarfe sondern ist es auch der einen
seite viel dies kann im prinzip auf der
anderen seite bedeutet aber auch
hauptsache die vermeintlich eigene
klientel zu bedienen geld auszuschütten
über jeweiligen zielgruppen ohne plan
ohne ziel und das gleichzeitig bei einer
aufnahme von neuen milliarden-schulden
und auch dass es etwas was eigentlich in
den letzten jahren schon mal mehr geeint
war zu sagen dass auf schuldenbergen
kinder nicht spielen können so ist da
die ausschussvorsitzende gesagt haben
ist der kinder am herzen liegen da muss
man sagen man kann doch die ampeln ärzte
schulden aufräumen dass keiner mehr
später die luft zum atmen
hätten ihr rennen und ich frage mich
manchmal also sie wollten unbedingt
regieren und jetzt wo sie es tun tun sie
es nicht regieren ist ein versprechen
die zukunft besser zu gestalten als die
gegenwart sie aber falsch einzuschätzen
wirft ihr weg nochmals fragen auch auch
ihre eigene zukunftskompetenz betreffen
jetzt gibt es zwei möglichkeiten
entweder sie tun's weiß es nicht besser
wissen oder mangels kompetenz oder eben
weil es im grunde egal ist hauptsache
ideologisch fähig und ich möchte schon
noch ein paar worte auf verlieren zum
demokratie fördergesetz was heuer noch
geschlossen werden soll abgesehen davon
dass es den großen block der
gesetzlichen leistungen noch einmal
weiter an fahrt es ist es eben auch
haushalterisch ein fass ohne boden
und jetzt man höre und staune und ich
will jetzt gar nicht völlig richtig dass
er uns ja einig dass wir auf jeden fall
entschieden was den rechtsextremismus
tun müssen völlig klar aber dass der
islamismus als demokratiegefährdend
reform gar nicht auftaucht obwohl es
rund 550 islamistische gefährder gibt
die verfassungsschutzberichte ist eben
auch für uns so dass der islamismus eine
reale gefahr ist für unsere offene
liberale gesellschaft in deutschland und
da würde ich sie einfach auch mal bitten
besser den zuschauern an dieser stelle
und wenn sie mir nicht glauben dann
brauchen sie vielleicht der eigenen
ampel wobei wie gesagt die kommunikation
unter den ampel fraktionen scheint ja
auch nicht so da zu sein wenn ich mal
die fdp anschauen mussten wir nur die
ministerin hat auch die faz zitiert ich
darf auch frau beste präsidentin die faz
zitieren gestern getitelt gegen anti
demokraten zu sein reicht nicht das
sagen nicht nur wir das sagt die fdp
innenpolitikerin der teuteberg sehr
zweifel ob das demokratie fördergesetz
die richtigen stark also vielleicht
fragen sie mal in der eigenen beamten
nach ob das alles so richtig ist was sie
hier vorschlagen an dieser stelle
dafür wollen sie im neuen haushaltsplan
die mittel auf satte 184 millionen
anheben obwohl im haushaltsjahr 21 116
millionen für das vorläufer programm
auch abgerufen wurden und deswegen sind
wir so strikt gegen eine verstetigung
weil es eine waage und eine umstrittene
sache ist und die frage es muss uns dann
eben haushalterisch antragsteller auch
einschränkt die wunschliste aus dem
koalitionsvertrag kennen wir sie es lang
davon sehen wir bislang sehr wenig
abgebildet stichwort seit ende was sie
auch so oft bemüht wird auch fehlanzeige
wir orientieren uns an den konkreten
bedarf für die kinder für die
jugendlichen für die seniorinnen und
senioren in diesem land für die frauen
deswegen haben wir uns an unter anderem
auch für ein neues kinderbetreuung
ausbauprogramm starke haben die sprache
schon angesprochen alles ganz konkrete
punkte die sie ganz leicht umsetzen
könne wenn sie unsere änderungsanträgen
zu stimmen darin nehmen die wirklich die
familie in unserem lande starken mit
wenigen geschickten ansatz veränderungen
im verein
ich wollte nur wissen ob sie die frage
von herrn zu lassen worden also da hat
ja schon heute zeit gehabt wenn ich
jetzt an der stelle nicht tun die
familie ist das rückgrat unserer
gesellschaft die mitte
die mitte auf wo deutschland seine sich
der menschlichkeit zeiten kann deswegen
nehmen sie bitte noch mal eine
neubewertung vor auch eine neubewertung
des koalitionsvertrags weil alle
rednerinnen und redner ja auch gesagt
haben dass sich die welt verändert hat
der koalitionsvertrag ist aus dem
letzten jahr bildet die realität nicht
mehr abstimmen sie unseren anträgen zu
dann tun sie etwas für die familien
herzlichen dank im
dorothee bär war dass die
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
der unionsfraktion ja und in dieser
debatte auch bei dorothee bär ein
dauerbrenner sozusagen das demokratie
fördergesetz das hat die union in der
letzten legislatur blockiert in dieser
soll es kommen mit der ampel
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir haben uns viel vorgenommen für den
bereich familien frauen jugend
seniorinnen und senioren im
koalitionsvertrag und uns ampel familien
politikerinnen und politiker und die
ganze ampel ein weitgehend die
vorstellung einer chancengerechten und
diskriminierungsfreien gesellschaft und
dazu gehört auch tüchtig was zu tun zur
stärkung der demokratie ich habe mal
nachgeguckt während hier die debatte
lief wir haben seit 2000 16
22 tote menschen opfer durch
rechtsextremismus meine lieben
kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben es
bitter nötig hier was zu tun und
und diese wir müssen auch diese
demokratie nächtlichen und den den
institutionen und repräsentantinnen und
repräsentanten
und gutes wünschen denn zum beispiel in
krabbelgruppen da ftd muss man auch
gesellschaftlich was entgegensetzen
meine lieben verlegen das machen wir die
demokratie stärken
es ist schon einiges auch gesagt mach
ich wollte noch hinweisen darauf der
islamismus frau kollegin wer ist
selbstverständlich auch in diesem
haushalt berücksichtigt auch damals war
was schon das problem ist durchaus auf
dem zettel jetzt noch mal zum haushalt
als solchen wir haben jetzt noch recht
wenig gehört zum thema frauen und
gleichstellung da dachte ich es mache
ich jetzt mal weil wir fahren da geht es
natürlich nicht nur um alleine um
karrierefrauen sondern die mütter wir
sind arbeitskolleginnen wir sind
ehefrauen partnerinnen nachbarin was
auch immer was uns alle einig wir sind
diskriminiert und deshalb ist es gut
dass wir den deutschen frauen hat
stärken in diesem haushalt es ist gut
dass die gleichstellung stiftung
finanziell verstetigt ist die hat
infortrend haken ersten geburtstag
herzlichen glückwunsch an die die damals
ausbauen
in summe der steuer auf ihre forderungen
tatsächlich mehr geld kriegt in diesem
jahr also das ist alles wunderbar warum
darüber hinaus sind wir familien
politikerinnen und familienpolitiker
immer auch total nett zu den anderen
arbeitsgruppen und ausschüssen weil wir
immer auch so viel brauchen von euch ich
freue mich zum beispiel darüber dass die
bundespolizei beim zeugs über eine
vierstellige summe mehr an personal
bekommen das ist auch gut in unserem
bereich wenn es um die frage
zwangsprostitution gilt wir freuen uns
darüber dass wir künftig bafög an bis 45
jahre weil dann auch kobe lebensläufe
von frau und kind und so weiter eben
auch berücksichtigung finden das
elterngeld geht hoch die um fast 270
millionen euro und manches kostet
einfach auch gar nichts zum beispiel
wenn wir den § 209 10 anstreichen
regierung zu leben nach den ausgemachten
haushalt nichts vor dem haus hat wir
waren jetzt in 22 der haushalt und haben
den 23 24 25 er tatsächlich im blick es
geht natürlich um diese riesen projekte
die wir uns vorgenommen haben schutz vor
gewalt kindergrundsicherung muss gut
vorbereitet sein dass gute kita gesetzt
wollen wir weiterführen das futter schon
dazu und wir wir sind hier möglich sind
die ampelkoalition toll und ich finde
aber auch toll dass wir nicht über alles
in harmonie puderzucker drüberstreuen
und deshalb möchte ich der kollegin
raffelhüschen ein berg stelle auch sagen
lassen sie uns doch bitte nicht die
kinder gegen die alten aus spiel des
sollten wir nicht machen das hätte ganz
ganz gut finden lassen sie uns die
perfekte ende die wir uns vorgenommen
haben
yamaha jetzt in 22 der haushalt fällig
haben den 23er im blick ich bedanke mich
bei rein haushälterinnen und haushalt
bei unserer kollegin elisabeth kaiser
bei den haushalten der anderen anderen
fraktionen sehr für ihre arbeit ich
freue mich auf die weitere
zusammenarbeit und ich freue mich auf
ein gutes arbeiten im familienausschuss
für die familien in diesem land
herzlichen dank sagte leni breymaier für
die spd die familienpolitische
sprecherin hier letzte rednerin zu
diesem einzuplanen
ich schicke die aussprache und wir
kommen zur abstimmung über den
einzelplan 17 des bundesministeriums für
familie senioren frauen und jugend in
der ausschuss fassung hierzu gibt es
einen änderungsantrag der fraktion der
cdu/csu auf drucksache 20 37 wer stimmt
für diesen änderungsantrag
wer stimmt dagegen
wer enthält sich das machten die afg
enthaltung
damit ist der änderungsantrag abgelehnt
zugestimmt haben die cdu csu fraktion
und die fraktion die linke dagegen haben
gestimmt spd bündnis 90/die grünen und
fdp und die afg hat sich enthalten
jedenfalls die meisten ja dagegen ist
der union noch mal darum verschiedene
titel im einzelplan zu erhöhen
beispielsweise die zuweisung an die
stiftung frühe hilfen noch mal um einige
millionen das hat hier keine mehrheit
gefunden jetzt wird über den einzelplan
abgestimmt damit der einzelplan
angenommen bei zustimmung durch die
koalition die opposition hat geschlossen
dagegen gestimmt damit rufe ich ja genau
und das ist sozusagen das
parlamentarische vorgehen hier in den
haushaltsberatungen zweite beratung zum
einzelplan am freitag dann wenn alle
einzelpläne gelesen worden sondern
zweiter beratung die dritte beratung zum
haushaltsgesetz und den einzelplänen
dann in der schlussabstimmung